malheureusement non en fait puisque avec
le système de fonctionnement de l'onu
les cinq membres permanents dont la
russie ont toujours la possibilité
d'émettre un droit de veto donc ce soir
à new york au conseil de sécurité les
etats-unis appellent à cette zone
démilitarisée autour de sap aurait déjà
de cette centrale nucléaire est donc la
plus grande d'europe et qui permettrait
effectivement si elle était réalisée de
sécuriser véritablement cette centrale
quand même qu'il ya six tranches donc ça
fait 6000 mégawatts c'est quand même
considérable mais voilà ça ne sera
certainement pas le cas les russes et
les ukrainiens s'accusent mutuellement
de de frappe autour de la centrale
c'était encore le cas aujourd'hui ce
jeudi ce qui effectivement est très
dangereux et les ukrainiens affirment
qu'en fait les russes ont bien
d'entendre le président cnce qui ont en
quelque sorte
instrumentaliser la centrale développant
des moyens militaires autour de la
centrale en sachant très bien que si les
ukrainiens attaquent leurs installations
aux russes et bien il y aura des dégâts
et à ce moment là il pourrait en rendre
responsables les ukrainiens donc les
russes disent évidemment l'averse bref
on est un peu malheureusement dans une
impasse est-ce que la situation est
aussi dangereuse que le dit le président
ukrainien alors pour le moment selon les
informations qui sont difficiles à
remonter parce que justement les les les
inspecteurs de l'aiea l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique ne
peuvent pas se rendre sur place mais
enfin selon les informations qui
remontent à l'onu et aux états unis pour
le moment aucun réacteur n'a été touché
il n'y a donc pas de niveau si vous
voulez de radioactivité anormale on est
là quand même dans une espèce de
précaution parce que effectivement
potentiellement s'il y a un des
réacteurs qui est touché ou des
installations sensibles là effectivement
colisée le président hélène ski ça
pourrait être du niveau de tchernobyl
voire pire voire bien pire si quelque
chose se passe toute la question en fait
ce soir c'est de savoir si les russes
vont continuer à jouer
ce bras de fer ce qu'ils savent très
bien qu'avec zappos ridja ils ont une
arme potentiellement de destruction très
importante et qui donc il on joue en
ukraine ils ont d'ailleurs annoncé qu'il
comptait organiser dans la région de zap
orridge un référendum pour arrimer cette
région à la russie et côté ukrainien
évidemment il faut la plus grande
réserve pour ne pas tirer contre les
russes tout près de sept centrales
nucléaires